the open questions there are
what does the manifestation of super
intelligence look like
so like what are we going to you talked
about why do i want to merge with ai
like what
what's the actual marginal benefit here
if i
if we have a super intelligent system
yeah how will it make our life better
so let's let's that's a great question
but let's break it down to little pieces
all right on the one hand it can make
our life better in lots of simple ways
you mentioned like a care robot or
something that helps me
do things it cooks i don't know what it
does right little things like that we
have soup better smarter cars
we can have you know better agents and
aids helping us in our work environment
and things like that to me that's like
the easy stuff the
simple stuff in the beginning um
and so in the same way that computers
made our lives better in
ways many many ways i will have those
kind of things
to me the really exciting thing about ai
is
sort of its transcendent transcendent
quality in terms of humanity
we're still biological organisms we're
still stuck here on earth
it's going to be hard for us to live
anywhere else i don't think
you and i are going to want to live on
mars anytime soon
and um and we're flawed
you know we may end up destroying
ourselves it's
totally possible uh we if not completely
we could destroy our civilizations
you know it's let's face the fact we
have issues here
but we can create intelligent machines
that can help us in various ways for
example one example i gave
and that sounds a little sci-fi but i
believe this if we really want to live
on mars we'd have to have intelligent
systems that go there
and build the habitat for us not humans
humans are never gonna do this it's just
too hard
um but could we have a thousand or ten
thousand you know
engineer workers up there doing this
stuff building things terraforming mars
sure
maybe we can move mars but then if we
want to if we want to go around the
universe
should i send my children around the
universe or should i send some
intelligent machine which is like a
child
that represents me and understands our
needs here on earth
that could travel through space um so
it's sort of
in some sense intelligence allows us to
transcend our
the limitations of our biology uh
with and and don't think of it as a
negative thing it's in some sense
my children transcend my the my biology
too
because they they live beyond me yeah um
and we impart
they represent me and they also have
their own knowledge and i can impart
knowledge to them so intelligent
machines will be like that too
but not limited like us but the question
is
um there's so many ways that
transcendence can happen
and the merger with ai and humans is one
of those ways so
you said intelligent basically beings or
systems
propagating throughout the universe
representing us humans
they represent us humans in the sense
they represent our knowledge and our
history
not us individually right
right but i mean the question is is it
just the database
with uh with the really damn good uh
model
no no they're conscious conscious just
like us okay
but just different they're different uh
just like my children are different
they're like me but they're different um
these are more different
i guess maybe i've already i kind of
i took a very broad view of our life
here on
on earth i said you know why are we
living here are we just living because
we live
is are we surviving because we can
survive are we fighting just because
we want to just keep going what's the
point of it yeah right
so to me the point if i ask myself
what's the point of life is
what transcends that ephemeral
sort of biological experience is
to me this is my answer is the
acquisition of knowledge
to understand more about the universe
and to explore
and that's partly to learn more right
i don't view it as a terrible thing
if the ultimate outcome of humanity
is we create systems that are
intelligent that are offspring but are
not like us at all
and we still we stay here and live on
earth as long as we can
which won't be forever but as long as we
can
and but that would be a great thing to
do
it's not a it's not like a negative
thing well
would uh you'd be okay then if uh
the human species vanishes but our
knowledge is preserved
and keeps being expanded by intelligent
systems
i want our knowledge to be preserved and
expanded
yeah am i okay with humans dying no i
don't want that to happen
but if if it does happen what if we were
sitting here and this is all
we were the last two people on earth and
saying lex we blew it it's all over
right yeah wouldn't i feel better if i
knew that our knowledge was preserved
and that we had agents represent that
knew about that that were trans
you know they were that left earth i
would want that
it's better than not having that you
know i make the analogy of like you know
the dinosaurs the poor dinosaurs they
lived for you know tens of millions of
years
they raised their kids they you know
they they fought to survive they were
hungry they
they they did everything we do and then
they're all gone
yeah like you know and and if we didn't
discover their bones
nobody would ever know that they ever
existed
right do we want to be like that i don't
want to be like
you